we are getting new insight into the
international manhunt for the killer of
a popular college student Haley Andersen
disappeared from her off-campus New York
apartment in 2018 her roommates
discovered she was murdered after using
the find my friends app to look for her
in this week's 48 hour is CBS News
contributor Maria Elena Salinas shows us
what investigators have uncovered when
Binghamton University nursing student
Haley Anderson first disappeared from
her off-campus apartment in March 2018
her close friend and roommate
Josie Orton says she wasn't alarmed I
didn't think oh something terrible has
happened because you know Hilly's a big
girl but the next day
Josie became extremely concerned
especially when another roommate
used the app find my friends to track
Haley's phone to the apartment of fellow
nursing student Orlando Tercero
tell me about Orlando Orlando is
charismatic Orlando's close friend Jesse
Bua knew how much Orlando liked Halley
the first thing I thought was maybe they
had eloped but Josie didn't trust
Orlando and went to his apartment in
search of her friend when no one
answered the door she climbed through a
window and found Hayley I didn't know
for sure that she was dead at the time
she just was so pale you know Hayley had
been strangled to death in Orlando they
said Oh was gone so this is the house
that Orlando lived in that is correct
Binghamton police lieutenant Cory miner
led the investigation into Hayley's
death in Orlando's disappearance there's
several different cameras on the house
the camera on the front of the house
shows miss Anderson and mr. Tercero
walking into the residence on March 8th
hours later
Orlando could be seen leaving the
apartment alone suitcase in hand born in
Miami and raised in Nicaragua the dual
citizen drove to New York's JFK Airport
and left the country who picked him up
at the airport in Nicaragua to this day
I don't know Binghamton's former
District Attorney Stephen corn well when
I learned he was in Nicaragua before we
could get to him the first thing I
thought was
no wait he got away with murder Maria
Elena Salinas joins us now Maria Elena
good morning so Orlando is a dual
citizen he leaves the United States for
Nicaragua what happens at that point
well he goes to the garage where no one
knows really for why he was running away
or if he attempted to commit suicide and
wanted to be with his family when that
happened but he did get arrested a few
days later even though there was not an
official order for his arrest in
Nicaragua and the US authorities had not
requested that arrest it seems like the
extensive media coverage is what
prompted the Nicaraguan authorities to
arrest him there and did the Nicaraguan
authorities cooperate with US
authorities and did US authorities try
to extradite Orlando yes and I think
that that's one of the most fascinating
parts of this story the cooperation that
existed between the US authorities and
the Nicaraguan authorities they did
charge him that money charged him with a
crime called femicide which is described
as a crime when a man kills a woman whom
he had a relationship with so there was
cooperation there was a trial that was
done via teleconferencing and the
outcome of this trial you will see
tomorrow